so without further ado I present the one
the only be lovable mr. Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much
all right hi how are ya hi she's holding
a child
one night so first things first where's
Liz get it home be hanging around
afterwards I'd like to begin by thanking
the class marshals for inviting me here
today the last time I was invited to
Harvard it cost me a hundred and ten
thousand dollars
so I was reluctant to show up I'm gonna
start before I really begin by
announcing my my one goal this afternoon
I want to be half as funny as tomorrow's
commencement speaker moral philosopher
and economist Amartya Sen that's the job
must get more laughs than Seminole wage
price theoretician by the way enjoy that
bring a calculator it's gonna be a nerd
fest students of the Harvard class of
2015 years ago I sat where you sit now
and I thought exactly what you are now
thinking what's going to happen to me
will I find my place in the world am I
really graduating a virgin still have 24
hours
roommates mom very hot
swear she's checking me out
there was that Rob Lowe movie being here
today being here today on a sincere note
is very special for me I do miss this
place
I especially miss Harvard Square let me
tell you you don't know this Harvard
Square is extremely unique nowhere else
in the world will you find a man wearing
a turban and a Red Sox jacket working in
a lesbian bookstore I'm just glad my
dad's working now personal choice it's
particularly sweet for me to be here
today because this is true when I
graduated I wanted very badly to be a
class day speaker
unfortunately my speech was rejected so
if you'll indulge me I'd like to read a
portion of that speech this is the
actual speech from 15 years ago
fellow students as we sit here today
listening to that classic AHA tune which
will definitely stand the test of time I
would like to make several predictions
about what the future will hold I
believe that one day a simple governor
from a small southern state will rise to
the highest office in the land
he will lacked political skill but will
lead on the sheer strength of his moral
authority I believe that justice will
prevail and one day the Berlin Wall will
crumble
uniting East and West Berlin forever
under communist rule I believe that one
day a high-speed network of
interconnected computers will spring up
worldwide so enriching people that they
will lose their interest in idle
chitchat and pornography and finally I
believe that one day I will have a
television show on a major Network seen
by millions of people a night which I
will use to reenact crimes and help
catch at large criminals and I had a
section on the death of Wall Street we
don't need to hear about that the point
is that although you see me as a
celebrity a member of the cultural elite
demigod if you will potential husband
material maybe the father of your child
improve it baby I came here
I came here in the fall of 1981 and I
lived here at home worthy actually I'm a
student much like you that's just sad
I was without exaggeration this is true
the ugliest picture in the freshman
Facebook when Harvard asked me for a
picture the previous summer this is a
true story I actually I thought it was
for their records so I literally just
liked their private records like in a
file so I jogged in the August heat to a
passport photo office and sat for a
morgue shot now this is that what
happened to make matters worse when the
Facebook came out they put my picture
right next to Catherine Oxenberg a
stunning blonde actress true story who
was accepted to the class of 85 but
decided to defer admission so she could
join the cast of dynasty folks my photo
would have looked bad on any page but
next to Catherine Oxenberg I looked like
a mackerel that had been in a car
accident you see in those days I was six
feet four inches tall and I weighed 150
pounds true recently I had some
structural engineers run those numbers
into a computer model and according to
the computer I collapsed in 1987 killing
hundreds in Taiwan after freshman year I
I moved to Mather house yeah now their
house very popular yeah matter house
incidentally was designed by the same
firm that built Hitler's bunker
in fact if Hitler had conducted the war
from Mather house he'd have shot himself
a year earlier saved us a lot of trouble
it's all the woohoo people from Mather
house were a little bum now 1985 seems
like a long time ago now when I had my
class day you students would have been 7
years old 7 years old you realize what
that means back then I could have beaten
any of you in a fight and I mean really
badly like no contest at all if anyone
here was a time machine seriously I will
kick your seven-year-old butt right now
a lot has happened in 15 years though
when you think about it we come from
completely different worlds when I
graduated in 1985 we watched movies
starring Tom Cruise and listened to
music by Madonna I come from a time when
we huddled around our TV sets and
watched The Cosby Show on NBC never
imagining that there would one day be a
show called Cosby on CBS in 1985 we
drove cars with driver's side airbags
but if you told us that one day they'd
be passenger side airbags would have
burned you for witchcraft
of course I think there is some common
ground between us I remember well the
great uncertainty of this day the
anxiety many of you were justifiably
nervous about leaving the safe
comfortable world of Harvard Yard and
hurling yourself headlong into the cold
harsh world of Harvard grad school a
plum job at your father's firm or a year
abroad with a gold MX card then a plum
job at your father's firm well let me
assure you that the knowledge you've
gained here at Harvard is a precious
gift that will never leave you take it
from me your education is yours to keep
forever why many of you have read The
Merchant of Florence and that will
inspire you when you travel to the
island of Spain
your knowledge of that problem they had
with those people in Russia or that guy
in South America you know the guy will
be with you for the rest of your life
there's also sadness today a feeling of
loss that you're leaving Harvard forever
let me assure you that you never really
leave Harvard the Harvard fundraising
committee will be on your ass until the
day you die
this is true I know for a fact that
right now a member of the Alumni
Association is at the Mount Auburn
cemetery shaking down the corpse of
Henry Adams they heard he has a brass
toe ring and they aims to get it now
imagine no offense buddy but got a lot
of nerve these people just raised 2.5
billion dollars and they only got
through the B's in the Alumni directory
here's basically how it works your phone
rings usually after a big meal when
you're sort of tired and most vulnerable
and a voice asks you for money now
knowing you've read in the paper that
they just raised 2.5 billion dollars you
ask what do you need it for then there's
a long pause and the voice on the other
end of line says we don't need it we
just want it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
carpe diem what else can you expect
let me see just buy your applause
quickly who here wrote a thesis thesis
all right that's nice that's nice a lot
of hard work a lot of your blood went
into that thesis and no one is ever
going to care
I wrote a thesis this is true I don't
lie
literary progeria in the works of
Flannery O'Connor and William Faulkner
let's just say that during my
discussions with Pauly Shore it doesn't
come up much three years after
graduation I wanted to show it to anyone
so I kept my thesis in the glove
compartment of my car so I could show it
to a policeman in case I was pulled over
supply since that's registration
cultural exploration of the man child in
the right I'll go what else can you
expect in the real world let me tell you
as you leave these gates and reenter
society one thing is certain everyone
out there is going to hate you Jacob is
right never tell anyone in a roadside
diner that you went to Harvard in most
situations the correct response to where
did you go to school his school I never
had much in the way of book learning and
such
then get in your BMW and get the hell
out of there go you see kids you're in
for a lifetime of and you went to
Harvard accidentally give the wrong
amount of change in a transaction and
it's and you went to Harvard ask the guy
at the hardware store how these jumper
cables work in here and you went to
Harvard forget just once that your
underwear it goes inside your pants and
it's and you think Harvard get your head
stuck in your niece's doll house cuz you
wanted to see what it was like to be a
giant and it's uncle Conan you go into
Harvard let's just slow this thing down
you see to really know what's in store
if you have to Harvard I'm gonna take
didn't change up a little bit here I
have to tell you what happened to me
after graduation I'm gonna tell it
simply I'm gonna tell it honestly I'm
going to tell you my story because first
of all I think my perspective may give
many of you hope and secondly it's such
a cool amazing rush to be in front of
6,000 people and just talk about
yourself so it's just great
now water if I want or not and you have
to wait kids excited parents who is this
man what's wrong with Ted Koppel guys
aren't something you see kids after
graduating in May I moved to Los Angeles
I got a three-week contract at a small
cable show I got a three hundred and
eighty dollar a month apartment terrible
dump and I bought a 1977 Isuzu Opel a
car Isuzu only manufactured for a year
because they found out that technically
it's not a car quick tip graduates no
four-cylinder used vehicle should have a
racing stripe so I worked at that show
for you know about a year
you're so feeling pretty good about
myself when one day they told me they
were letting me go I was fired I hadn't
saved any money so I tried to get
another job in television as best I
could and I couldn't find one couldn't
find any job in television so with
nowhere else to turn
true story I went to a temp agency and I
filled out a questionnaire and I made
damn sure that they knew I had been to
Harvard that I had written this thesis
and I expected the very best treatment
and so the next day I was sent to the
Santa Monica branch of Wilson's house of
suede and leather now when you have a
Harvard degree and you're working at
Wilson's house of suede and leather you
are haunted by the ghostly images of
your classmates who sue shows graduate
school you see their faces everywhere in
coffee cups you see them in fish tanks
you think you're going crazy and they're
always laughing at you as you stack
suede shirts no man in good conscience
whatever where I tried a lot of things
during this period acting in corporate
infomercials serving drinks in a
non-equity theater I even took a job
entertaining at a seven year old's
birthday party in desperate need of work
I put together some sketches and scored
a job at the fledgling Fox Network as a
writer and performer for a brand new
show called the Wilton North Report I
was finally on a network and really
excited the producer told me the show
was going to revolutionize television
and in a way it did the show was so
hated and did so badly
when four weeks later news of its
cancellation was announced to the Fox
affiliates they burst into spontaneous
applause that had never happened before
in television eventually though I got a
big break I had submitted along with my
writing partner a batch of sketches to
Saturday Night Live and after a year and
a half they read it and they gave us a
two-week tryout the two weeks turned
into two seasons and I felt hey this is
success I'm successful now successful
enough to write a TV pilot for an
original sitcom and when the network
decided to make it feeling good I leave
Saturday Night Live time to go to hell
now this this TV show was gonna be
groundbreaking this new one it was gonna
resurrect the career of TV's Batman Adam
West it was gonna be a comedy without a
laugh track or a studio audience it was
gonna change all the rules and here's
what happened when the pilot aired it
was the second lowest rated television
show of all time it's actually tied with
a test pattern they show in Nova Scotia
so I was 28 once again no job I had good
writing credits in New York but I was
filled with disappointment and I had no
idea what I was going to do next I
started smelling suede on my fingertips
and that is when the Simpsons saved my
life I got a job there I started writing
episodes about Springfield getting a
monorail or home or going to college I
was finally putting my Harvard education
to good use writing dialogue for a man
who's so stupid that in one episode he
forgot to make his own heartbeat life
was good and then an insane inexplicable
opportunity came my way a chance to
audition for host of the new late-night
show I took the opportunity very
seriously but at the time I have to be
honest I had the relaxed confidence of
someone who knew he had no real shot so
I couldn't fear losing a great job that
I had never had that I couldn't hope to
have and I think that actually that that
attitude made the difference I will
never forget being in the Simpsons
recording basement that morning when the
phone rang it was for me my car was
blocking a fire lane
but a week later I got another call I
got the job so this finally was
undeniably it the truly life-altering
break that I had always dreamed of and I
went to work I gathered all my funny
friends and poured all my years of
common experience into building the show
over the summer I gathered the talent
figured out the sensibility found max
found Andy found my people we debuted on
September 13th 1993 and I was really
happy really happy with our effort I
felt like I had seized the moment that I
had put my very best foot forward and
this is what the most respected and
widely read television critic Tom Shales
wrote in The Washington Post is actually
quote O'Brien is a living collage of
annoying nervous habits he giggles and
titters jiggles about and fiddles with
his cuffs he has dark beady little eyes
like a rabbit he's one of the whitest
white men ever
O'Brien is a switch on the guests who
won't leave he's the host who should
never have come let the Late Show with
Conan O'Brien become the Late Late Show
and may the hosts return to Conan
oblivion whence he came
end quote there's more but it gets kind
of mean needless to say I took a lot of
criticism some of it deserved some of it
excessive and I'll be honest with you it
hurt like you would not believe but I'm
telling you all this for a reason I have
had a lot of success I have had a lot of
failure I've looked good and I've looked
bad
I've been praised and I've been
criticized but my mistakes have been
necessary except for Wilson's houses
waiting that was stupid don't do that
I've dwelled on my failures today
because as graduates of Harvard your
biggest liability is your need to
succeed you need to always find yourself
on the sweet side of the bell curve
because success is a lot like a bright
white tuxedo you feel terrific when you
get it but then you're desperately
afraid of getting it dirty of spoiling
it in any way I left the cocoon of
Harvard I left the cocoon of Saturday
Night Live
I left the cocoon of The Simpsons and
each time it was bruising and tumultuous
and yet every failure was freeing and
I'll be honest with you today I'm as
nostalgic for the bad as I am for the
good so that's what I wish for all of
you the bad as well as the good fall
down make a mess
break something occasionally give this
guy a hard time know that your mistakes
are your own unique way of getting to
where you need to be and remember that
the story is never over if you'll
indulge me for just a second I'd like to
read a little something from just this
year somehow Conan O'Brien has
transformed himself into the brightest
star in the late-night firmament his
comedies the gold standard
Coenen himself is not only the quickest
and most inventive width of his
generation but quite possibly the
greatest host ever
ladies and gentlemen class of 2000 I
hope that this morning
as proof that when all else fails you
always have delusion I will go now to
make bigger mistakes and to embarrass
this fine institution even more but let
me leave you with one last thought if
you can laugh at yourself loud and hard
every time you fall people will think
you're drunk thank you
you